a couple things you guys need to know if
you're watching this don't know why
needs back the Boston kid is back
number two the shoes that Brent is
wearing may look like regular black
running shoes with patent leather but
their Mariano which means their bunnies
ma Gianni it doesn't matter but they're
probably at least $600 now those the
boots I bought you they're not but you
love those those are landing the frames
there's a ND difference those are the
shawshank yeah I wear both
now don't we I want to apologize because
Brendan and I are kind of like we're a
little hoarse today from our shows yeah
I look yesterday cannot speak when you
called me on it context only I didn't
talk all day yeah and I'm back you're
behind if it's more it's more of a sexy
voice three shows in a day
well I text you it takes you Rogan and
D'Elia okay you only had another show I
was like we've done that yeah yeah I
should have said absolutely not it's
ended up in the hospital I'm in Denver
and I do three show seen a thin the airs
I also had a cold along I also hadn't
been sleeping how long ago was this Oh
probably five six years ago when I was
doing um in plain sight whenever that
was now here's the great here's the
clincher so he did three shows in Denver
high altitude yeah yes tough talk well I
ended up in the hospital on tow right
away go neutral huh went to go do shows
there and couldn't breathe I couldn't
breathe and I was lying down I couldn't
breathe so I said I'm having a heart
attack went to the hospital they ran all
these hard tests on me in Toronto I seem
to have been fine they said you don't
have any heart issues you're just
probably exhausted overworked couldn't
sleep all night though and then uh I
didn't you can't sleep not definitely
not in the hospital and you're not when
you're traveling you're okay yeah you
know you're all I'm on La time I'm doing
press the whole thing's a disaster
I got a very rare disease that only
children get called foot-and-mouth
disease my friend I've heard you get
some listeners know your feet know you
get blisters
I put my hands in my pocket for Zach and
I mean think about this I put my hands
in my pocket
oh I'm sorry and I've gone to Vegas to
do a show right after that I put my hand
in my pocket I went ooh that hurts what
what happened why don't I have blisters
on my hands that night I had blisters on
my feet on the bottom of my feet my
hands and feet yeah that's not good now
that's where you get yourself checked
for syphilis or something weird I don't
know I was like now my hands were
covered in blisters in my the bottom my
feet think about how fun this would be
and on the end of your toes that's a
good time to put your shoes in your feet
in so long story short I go to the
doctor immediately because I I knew this
surgeon who got me in I I'm in New
Mexico I get there the guy goes holy
[ __ ] open your mouth I open my mouth he
goes whoa dude I think you have foot and
mouth let me I'm gonna go get the
pediatrician the PDA whatever he calls
me pediatrician comes in and goes I
haven't seen a case like this in an
adult and so long damn how did you get
my buddy called me up and goes he's a
doctor and he goes Brian's left oh stop
this [ __ ] you're not sleeping and
you're getting weird [ __ ] there is no
reason that the only time an adult gets
that as if they're completely wiped out
and I just you know you keep grinding
keep grinding
yeah foot-and-mouth I go oh there's the
best part I go well I have blisters on
my feet I've never been more
uncomfortable and I have a cold can you
tell me how I get rid of this thing oh
it's self-correcting rest
self-correcting just rest yeah I have
about ten days
enjoy that ten days it's tough when they
want to do is shown in Calgary you were
right man the Calgary scene was [ __ ]
amazed amazed it was great
there's the nicest people in the world
in crowd and the owners of Yuk Yuk's
Kevin and Angie Kevin ooh yeah Angie's
amazing yeah but there's Dale no no and
also uh God he's gonna kill me he's my
boy he's uh Scott got daddy's got so I
love those guys so Craig you know we do
that shirt the shirts yeah we'd sell
merch and I'm doing the meet-and-greet
and uh one of the guys come up to me and
Canadians are they're so nice they come
up to me I'm in the background that's
got like
we got a problem I'm like what I haven't
seen these guys panic at all me we got a
problem
I know if you heard or not like oh [ __ ]
something's going down man yes someone
took a shirt someone I hope I apologize
on the behalf of Calgarians and he's
like getting choked Avia's someone took
your shirt I know what
so someone to get singular so do you see
no serious yeah I know I don't give a
[ __ ] man oh I don't care at all give
them away it's all good man yeah it's
not good and goes I'm on it no no no and
he leaves I don't know no it's not
you leave listen this I'm doing great
Jays there you know we're doing a thing
security and those three guys come
rushing in and I'm like what the what
and I forgot we had that what's
happening is he's there and they have a
picture they went through the video my
or the time to hit that and have this
full one picture of this guy looking guy
and I'm talking to the guy they tell you
were yeah can they take him down
that's [ __ ] hell I literally take him
down him and his buddy take him out the
building I'm like I guys I ski and have
the shirt it's not a big deal like this
shirt like not on our watch not on our
time like they were the best yeah you're
right like that Chris Chris LaBelle yeah
well the nicest guys in the great guy
great guy great guy really really well
too right yeah yes funny man comic he
had a bit in the back when he's doing
with me and Jay about this black comic
in LA and he was mimicking him and it's
one of ours times I've ever laughed Mike
dude you have to onstage like really
like he's that he's very good at it
Chris is really good at tech characters
he's fun really getting good yeah he was
hilarious yeah dude you have funny he's
a talented dude he really he's a real
comic yeah like he's at you know can't
get
Canada's got good comedy and you know
Chris is one guys from Canada sir oh
yeah yeah yeah no they have a whole
tradition you know it was in Canada when
I was at the same time Ellen DeGeneres
doing all across the street in Calgary
across this didn't matter though did it
you got fans no but
the completely different demographic but
also shoes to filming The Ellen Show
she'll do stand-up anyone I know which
is a tragedy I know she does Q&A still
money money can sometimes unless you're
Joe Rogan or bill burr or one of those
guys and money can he has been known to
[ __ ] up
TB gigs and money had not been known the
[ __ ] up many a stand-up a great stand-up
career but also being that we'll never
have to be creative to that's gonna
happen let's go and save that time start
when Brian said that not in a year from
now this is Brian you know I
it's been a good run stand out on me I
am Susan to got cream I'm never doing
the price is right but let me explain
they're given me six million dollars a
year leave you drew Carey and they're
like a price is easy when you've been on
the road grinding your whole life and
then you're 55 and they go here's a six
million dollar check and you go oh my
god the weather's nice here going harder
than coming up with new material oh my I
don't have to do that I mean just the
travel and sitting in a hotel alone your
stand-up is a solitary process you're
alone and and oh you know to get good
you kind of have the Rogen was talking
about this you know part of what like so
so the more popular to get you can do
less shows for more money so you can go
do a Friday night make a [ __ ] a lot of
money you're not getting good you have
to do when you see dudes that are doing
five six shows a weekend that's how you
get good that's how [ __ ] change and and
so that grind is your scroll talked
about it I don't care how famous you are
in some towns you're at the Best Western
you're at a hotel that's you know you're
you can smell that rub bum yeah yeah man
yeah it'll bum you out you've gotta
loosen you and daliyah pictures me in
the green room by myself
yep every show you good you are you are
a pack animal you don't like being alone
you're not a solitary gonna wear me your
mister team at least I'm a solitary [ __ ]
are you good at it then so Scalia but
you're you're you you like a support
system man I like to be funny how any
funny how you are that way but you chose
fighting I know
and you chose stand-up what's that about
I don't know [ __ ] you know what I mean
you talk to someone no no I I think that
there that's we do things like I feel
said the community
stand up yeah you do on the state even
though I'm on stage I feel I feel like I
represent you rogue and the crowd right
sure sugar I feel like I'm part of this
Rat Pack yeah I'm the weird new guy that
gets shot in Shawshank Redemption the
young kid you know but I'm that get
around yeah you get pure red yeah
they rub one out organs any different
rub one out let me get in there first
the young kid who everyone likes me eyes
yeah yeah well that's what understanding
sorry hey yeah yeah
Boston was good dollar I love boss man
that's our town that day you got some
fighter in the kid fans in Boston that's
one of the places I you know recognizes
Brian Cowen do you know I'm saying oh
not bright inside kid I thought we were
on this journey that's not what I was
gonna say I don't know I'm sorry
why did you face my sins with that I
don't know is that something you think
No
then why'd you say it out loud for the
peeler thing why'd you say it out loud
and why is my boy so clear and why is
your voice not because because I'm not
I'm telling the truth and it seems to me
you're lying
I demand let's do a voice lesson right
now drop your larynx now no I can't try
it
relax your larynx think it down and open
your mouth try it lay off me I'm storm
no try it again try it again try it
again try it again
it does feel nice I can hear that but
I'm talking like this like you're
yawning try this oh you kept a key I'm
losing my voice like dude
drop your lyrics you keep telling me
that yeah and we tell you I want to
strangle you keep it down tell me that
for years you go down I can't do it well
I'm fine my voice is back kinda sort of
it was gone yesterday I'll quit talking
after we do the show yeah rest of the
day you know my son's like what the
[ __ ] wrong with my dad or whatever
yeah yeah Boston though I love it man
it's a great place it really is I I
walked for miles through Boston it's I
would say it's the best walking town in
some ways it can be because the office
in New York can go everywhere but we've
gone subway there
history man you see buildings that were
there you know then therefore since the
founding of the nation it's kind of wild
you see old statues and I think that the
low population knows that they're part
of a very deep tradition of root-like
where laughs Boston is where Southie was
where Whitey Bulger ranch you love them
yeah so there's all these that was a
very rough place now of course it's
completely gentrified back in the day he
ran that town yeah yeah whitey there
you've been athletes from there and yeah
there was the Irish then there was the
Italian mafia actually ran everything
correct you know it's pretty wild man
pretty well but Calgary first time he'd
been in Calgary first time some guy came
up to me after the show
older gentleman because dude I feel like
you and Brian are so mean to each other
these days well at what that does no no
no no that's so funny I said everyone
better
I love no I'm worried about you guys
Aria do you know what Canada's national
animal is who don't tell me chin don't
google it Chi and I I'm getting all
ready but uh you want the first what
were you gonna say
I should know this that's it now think
of all the animals in Canada yes [ __ ]
moose I was gonna guess moose or elk not
a bad guess
you're wrong no it's wrong it's a
Wolverine not a bad guess they're wrong
badger you're not a bad guess you're
wrong you got a polar bears you got
wolves you got all kinds like bears
brown bears all that stuff white bears
you'd think it'd be a polar bear no lot
of polar bears moves I think Jen I think
moose yeah I think most it's a beaver
Danny I was gonna say that but he said
badger are those almost the say old
beaver dam how funny kind of a lame in I
think because they used to be tracked a
lot that's where the trappers were gonna
first a lot of furs
after the show called uh I forget what's
called frontier yeah their trade well
you know listen a beaver blanket nothing
like it on your body let's be honest I'm
not saying you should kill animals and
you know skin and for their fur but if
you had to if you had to and you had the
cash yeah that or a hamster
I'm stair well the Apostles the Mongols
used to take the field home stairs and
well really well they would eat German
groundhogs well the Mongols would take
field mice and they would cut them up in
a little piece and they would make coats
out of the fur of the mother first oh
it's a lot it's a it's in it's a
labor-intensive thing they used to also
take Marmot they just take Marmot and
they would they would hollow it out and
put hot rocks in it that's how they'd
cook it then you need Marmot well it
would also drink fermented mares milk
this is disgusting delicious you know
Buster a friend sium I'm a Buster comes
on the road he sells our shirts
that's right needle buster yeah he's
also a serial killer your chance to meet
you in cahoots killing people what ones
in Seattle ones down here if you guys
moved in together as a couple I wouldn't
know I'd pay for you but the thing is is
uh in Canada he ordered a rabbit
straight-up rabbit ah to eat yeah yeah
disgusting
I've eaten rabbit for breakfast yet
rabbit and duck rabbit is how like that
buster moment what's wrong with you but
rabbit and duck are both delicious you
like rabbits greasy right it's no it's a
white flaky meat better than chicken No
oh yeah oh they're good they're
delicious
you'd love rabbit I can't believe never
absolutely I need bro it's not gamy at
all stewed rabbit is not gamy at all
ducks
you got a rabbit that's a slow-roasted
pork shoulder and I also love duck is
super greasy um
yeah duck is greasy but I it's a darker
meat but I love it it definitely taught
me when you get wild turkey you get a
wild Tom you know when you when you
bagged yourself a Tom sorry this is
hunter talk and you skin that Tom when
you dress the Tom and the Restless
through hanging upside down do a lot of
stuff bro
um the legs the legs on a domestic
turkey why I mean I mean the dark start
you break a Tom down you dress it on the
legs the door got some dark
bloody muscle me you know those are
actually hard fear for you at the dark
means actually healthier Centurions
because of the blood that's probably
what they say that's what they say yeah
white meats not as healthy I will always
tap a Toms vein I'll capture a Tom tap
it's a little vein drink it's turkey
blood and then set it free a little Tom
Tom don't fly you know a Tom can fly a
turkey can fly into a tree and then
they'll roost in a tree they call it
roosting when you hunt a turkey what's
the guy tell you when you never hunt
turkey he goes like this
Steve Rinella goes you have to
understand something about a turkey
everybody wants to eat a turkey
everybody in the [ __ ] forest wants to
eat a turkey your food your your food on
two legs and you got a beak yeah they're
the trolls of wildlife everybody wants
to give the trolls like ya the internet
trolls of human beings their turkeys and
they they just they're just prey they're
just they're yeah they're big fat your
your job job is get eaten the [ __ ]
that's right your job is to be to be
loved to be just a bunch of stupids and
get eaten up correct they're a bunch of
stupids and they are although they're
very cautious you're talking about it
like like people who study turkeys very
boring I don't care I don't care about
druggies no you know it's own studying
turkeys and people tell me about turkeys
and you know it's worse than people tell
you my turkeys being a turkey that'd be
a shitty deal yeah yeah you don't want
to be a turkey now have you ever thought
about they always they always describe
consciousness as like yet something has
to be conscious a sentient being for it
free and the way to define eyes it it
would have all vegans you know just have
to be it would be how I would have to be
be us to know what's going on you have
to know what it would be like to be that
right it has to be something like that
so so in other words what's it like to
be a turkey when it wakes up in the
morning what is it like is he like I'm
up I'm in the tree I got to come down I
got to eat I got a peck at the ground
and eat everything that I can find like
insects or whatever but the coyote the
Fox is there there are hawks so I got
threats from the ground and silent death
from the sky because owls and hogs
old man you're going hard on turkeys
right now yeah you're on hard on turkey
but can you imagine if you walked around
you have to worry about threats from the
sky and the ground
yeah looking up and you're looking down
all the time Brooks life bro for all of
us you know I mean you drunk out of here
yo guys you know you're like God why
don't you give me your eyes on the top
of my head i'd-- see my friend get
plucked away [ __ ] with your black
turkey yeah yeah they're black hey chin
see if you can find it hawk grabs doc no
one watch this with my to target all
this to be gettin switch to the doctor
different animal hawk with turkey to
watch what they do they come down
turkeys they're actually you know
turkeys a duck right yeah
turkeys are [ __ ] know I've seen this
with my own eyes my I was with my
daughter without candy can you see that
bro
which one second one yeah that [ __ ] I've
had this sit two counts boring ass
navigation of turkeys at least wanna see
a duck his head ripped off oh but
they're just gonna do some pork you see
how they just took the hood off that
Falcon mm-hmm yeah they're always
hilariously Falcons are ruthless you
know [ __ ] they go hunting I'll go find
you a duck and bring it back in that
incredible what human beings are able to
do this how you harness nature guys you
get your dog to flush the duck what
we're doing is flushing ducks right
never end do you really need a flush
okay I'll just kind of go down and flush
him now your shotguns not gonna reach
that far your scatter gun ain't gonna
catch seven you gotta get em flying over
directly over you you understand me okay
that that Hawk just grabbed its self a
duck no no look at that grab it in that
incredible okay can we have some better
[ __ ] camera work here it's do that
dog is trying to [ __ ] things up guys
what are you eat them they eat the
feathers
yeah ducks are cool-looking one
beautiful how can the stupid oh look at
that the ruthless disregard for how it
eats slight a feather because you need
to learn that's why
sorry you guys have to see that person
all due respect anybody is a vegan
that's just that's what happens in in
the wild in the water part of them did
you have good food in Boston I did have
good food in Boston I had I'm trying to
stay away from cheese of course cuz I'm
cholesterol or zombies they had this
goddamn this I walk into this restaurant
I knew I should have turned around him
and they had a pig's leg on this thing
and I knew I looked at on that pig's leg
is from Spain or it's from [ __ ] the
past Greece also known as called a Mon
its embarrassed so John cheese but it's
a pig and it is it's so delicious they
sell by the alleys but it's not got
myself $38 worth it's not cheese I got
myself $38 worth a shaved pork leg and I
hate that it was so beautiful it was so
beautiful then I had I had some I had
this de Sam n' fried rice that this this
Chinese woman like she grew up making of
some special way she did it was it was
[Music]
it was delicious
then I had a then she had a garden and I
had pea tendrils avocado
did you go eat with you know some
old-timers alone was the other Gardens
alone but then those he denies me from
the Goldbergs and she brings me out a
crazy crazy good cheese plate I mean I
think you and goat cheese can't be rude
I had to eat it can be rude yeah
can't be rude I ate the [ __ ] out of it
if I died of a heart attack you had a
Rogen you the what a show though what a
show oh they're so bad Thursday night
listen this Thursday night Rogan did an
hour yeah Brian did an hour Tony in
science they've got
fifteen minutes did 15 minutes Rovin
does an hour than I do an hour Stevie
did ten minutes let us show Stevie was
dempsey it was it Stevie MC yeah Tony do
20 minutes it's crazy then bro got your
money's worth on Thursday you got your
money's worth when you clock sakes
unbelievable cuz Rogen was like because
I knew you wanted to work as she goes
you guys I'll do you know I'll just do
you know 20 minutes if that's okay and I
go no you'll do an hour you're working
you're [ __ ] hour because no I would
never do that I go well you will you
will because it makes no difference to
me and also you got to get ready for
your one hour and people who love ya do
an hour I don't give a [ __ ] I don't care
at all he only did he did thirtieth
twenty or thirty minutes for my show
okay but it was 25 he shot his hour the
next day after yours heard he knocked it
in this from Tony in scope still miss
heard he knocked down the park on the
first try
did his new hours is great I love been
on Harvey Weinstein male I laugh so hard
so good I'm so hard so good yeah monster
doubt Tony who's Tony his cooks killing
it right now yeah yeah it's all good man
it's all good group I totally hitch
covers a huge WWE fan and I had uh I was
between a Saturday night between shows
two and three or yep between two and
three our boys from yesterday in the
back I was in the green room my brother
and they go I just let you know you have
a special guest in the front row but
don't draw any tension would call him
out like who is it like it's Bret the
Hitman Hart Lee Bret the Hitman Hart
somebody garden is number one Russell in
the world of all time is that right yeah
and oh he owns Calgary sir born and
raised his family or teachers there his
dad as a had a whole [ __ ] house they
were all the kid wrestle you know that's
his niece who's you know a storm for the
WB now Wow
yet but he had a heart attack recently
or a little bit ago beat heart attack in
cancer but he was there like he was
little
how how many he was there what two had
the best stories man I bet he did
Bret the Hitman Hart he had cancer too
yeah had cancer something like the best
ending wrestler fault
right and he told some great stories
great guy but it was weird because the
only hues J's favorite wrestler as a kid
growing up and he would only stare at J
really he was just like this Sanjay
you know J's not great with no so J's
all how are these they're all your days
like this yeah
how old is Ben Jay Jay goes must be 70
no I don't know how it is but Jay goes
dude I feel like you're staring to my
soul by the way he was Jay goes 680 she
goes we had a moment I went you got
about a 30 minute moment that you guys
were gonna [ __ ] become tag-team
partner [ __ ] 60 G Rob and his brother
know Oh Owen Hart was a WWE wrestler WWF
so I use the guy who's doing a style
fella by Jack I said he was the glue to
the family I'd love to get him on the
pocket out to be honest heart man to be
honest he be great on here he dead
serious though he needs more of a
three-hour platform him and Rogan
together it'd be epic I know Romans I'm
too ready so much so many stories and
lived a hard life I would imagine yeah
when your brother dies the family of
like seven and they had their issues
that will cause you a heart attack had a
beautiful wife
what younger no joke well he's not
playing around you understand that
cancer planetaries I don't know why
that's what she is not playing around I
sent that to you in Delhi I said Brian
close your eyes Julia you like till he
goes I love you respond back [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] change my outfit for every show
brought change of clothes
first show second show through show
difference went right through my clothes
yeah I don't sweat no I run you know how
I burn hot burn hobro a run hot oh we
didn't illegally stream the fights
either in the back because now on fs1 so
we can pull a Bryan Callen steal from
these poor farmers no we didn't watch
the ketamine just dismantle I was saying
this I'm below the belt in maybe you nod
I'd like just a general perspective on
this
when khabib absolutely destroyed Barboza
yeah we all said he was the next coming
up baby Jesus in Russian form
yeah heavenly does the same thing but
worse and no one's saying [ __ ] this
morning um yeah and that's a really
really good point
and maybe it's because Edson Barboza as
awesome as he is is always been known as
a very explosive striker but we're not
surprised has now struck them yeah I
know I know that's the other problem and
and but I wait to come down you could
say you did more damage and khabib did
he's gonna go first you ounce 10 8 when
I saw how great is his ground a pen yeah
when I saw its in space I was like I
don't want to watch this as I saw it on
Instagram thank God they stopped it but
but also I think also a lot of people
are I think a lot of people feel like
Kevin Lee is coming up and Edson's had
so many fights and coming off that
beating from number 5 in the world
though yes amazing I'm taking nothing
away from Edison but after taking a
beating like he did from khabib that
takes [ __ ] out of you JT has ties to all
while JDS came exactly exactly and so to
see Kevin do that I'm not taking any
away from Kevin Lee cuz he looked
amazing as well
he's on blows out to moments you also an
idea how good Tony Ferguson is and even
though Kevin had staff but it doesn't
matter now remember Tony Ferguson they
all have the same piss Barbossa
the common opponent Tony friggin was the
only one to finish him out of those guys
that's right the first is submitted with
a dark that is correct sir that is
correct and and I will say this and I
would say this I believe if Tony person
ever gets a crack at khabib I believe
Tony Ferguson beats could be oh wow yeah
I believe he loves me and I believe he
stopped that stops the takedown
ooh no sure if he takes him he gets
taken this trouble down in these days I
believe he gets on this back and he's
trouble on his back I believe he stands
up I believe he has his cardio's he's
got cardio for days
he's more creative as a fighter I think
as the fight goes on with khabib as he
lights them up more and more of those
takedowns become less frequent he's
Michael my money on Ferguson
um now I don't know Kevin Lee from are
you entertaining the idea of care you
are you playing with the idea of Kevin
Lee fighting kabila Lawson based on what
he did any fight great fight similar
styles or dozens more athletic or does
soubise better copy take them to the
ground and welcome he doesn't submit
people he just gets beat your opposition
haven't stuff to think down I think
he'll be picked on anyone in the world
yeah that's a great fight I don't know
what they're gonna have 55 this is my
whole kind of spiel rant on the
below-the-belt this morning was what do
you do at 55 it's so stacked as argument
that's important a Eddie Alvarez
Tony Ferguson's out Conor McGregor has
legal problems and then he got yeah
[ __ ] Kevin Lee there too so I
wouldn't mind seeing leave Poirier
actually I hope then what do you do with
Eddie Alvarez um I'm just not as excited
to watch Eddie as great as it is I'm not
as excited to watch Eddie Alvarez fight
as I am Kevin Lee and and Kevin Lee
would be the bigger like both those guys
if you really been if you're going off
base what the FC just does these days as
far as they don't care about yeah really
anything except for numbers yeah did you
watch the cup Swanson Frankie yeah right
thank God Yankee one make you look good
Frank he looked like his old self he
wasn't able to take down cub but that's
not saying anybody he looked great the
Showtime boxing your I didn't see it
because it's tough amazing well III the
problem is I have that iPad now and I
have the Showtime app so I watch all the
boxing and then below the belt well I'm
below the belt you damn right I do
because that comes up first on my thing
but I have to say that did you watch the
Adrien Broner Jesse Vargas fight I don't
mind a draw great fight I don't mind
draws right I don't mind draws this this
did everyone skill all up and up up in
arms about draws I don't mind drawn that
was a great fight man I'm gonna see you
draw than screw people over huh and I'm
gonna say this we'll say it say it out
loud when I watch boxing on that level
you think you know what you're doing
well number one is the number one I'm
gonna be honest and you know
for me I don't care you know I train
hard I'm gonna have a heart I'm gonna
have a [ __ ] hard time in the heart
making 144 147 147 no these guys were
Vargas was fighting at 42 44 I think in
this whatever is that same thing
welterweight it should be should be 47
and then 140 actually aim at 140 no
agent Brunner used to find it one I'm a
fighter 35 I might be able to suck down
to 40 either way these guys are gonna be
me in there they're [ __ ] cardio is
better than mine I'm seeing what they're
doing dude I think if you just get in
the gym more bro he could get there I
keep it first of all brother's not
hitting at that [ __ ] left hook that
he does all I said that's hilarious
I salute it I saluted I answer back but
Jesse Boggs did look a lot more battered
but he might catch weight correct catch
weight 44 catch with a 44 so I'm gonna
have a tough time making that so I'm
already dieting Adrien Broner was so
classless though I haven't seen that his
interviews are hilarious I don't watch
that you see wash is promoted yeah
that's him brother he's off [ __ ] you
know you're right before you think you
know you don't want me to win then
you're against me [ __ ] you gone gay and
[ __ ] him after the flu
don't disrespect me how you make us [ __ ]
you that [ __ ] easy he's ruthless
yeah that's his character but it's also
like after the fight after you have a
great fight like that he thanked him
said he's a warrior but I beat his ass
that's what they did you're gay he's
gone gay I was like no homo I think it
was a close fight but I wasn't a homo
yoram say that no homo bro what are you
even saying before the violent press
Capri press conference he knows
there ain't no man that's gonna be me
off this stadium no homo
I don't mean like v-mail no homo like
bro oh yeah relax you don't have to say
no matter of fact you say no home was
kind of offensive yeah and then saying
you're gay you said some [ __ ] at the end
of the fight you're gay man y'all better
may not be you I be light and he cause
did some gang thing blood Bloods or
something I was like [ __ ] bro you are
terrible all the way around no yeah
I think Albertson was like charming is
always a great Shelburne state is great
without Bernstein a boxer no he's
actually been he's been doing it forever
you know he's a musician
really yeah he's in Vegas he's a
phenomenal musician really yeah Wow
great great guy legend of the sport
didn't you see javante Davis yes sir god
damn he's good any great that dude is so
fast he was just standing right there
you can't hit him and he just can't
answers back pop pop pop you know what
the rock for him huh you don't know all
I know they have my favorite well I
don't have I mean I know who I'd like to
see who loved and Jenko did how dare you
that's what they want I don't think I
mean large it was smaller right well
they know they can dig invited that
invited that class would be terrible
idea why Perot for John today he's too
young so yeah man it's a terrible idea
God he looks good and everything he does
though he's a mom he looks good you
wouldn't feed him - you wouldn't feed
him - no jacket change his career path
no much anger does would he you know
he's that good know what Jake is the guy
like he'll fight world champions and get
them to quit like they don't answer the
bell you don't want that it's not like a
young cannot only fought Floyd
you know I'd be honest with you I have
trouble seeing that with javontae Davies
I've watched Sony I'm surprised that
he's so powerful you know we're near low
change level he's just not on that there
I don't know anyone that is but it's not
him right now
God man you might hit harder you didn't
have the skills to make it 12 round
early no how old is Javonte young man 24
I think 22 23
it was the youngest chance for a while
yeah give him some time give him some
time to it so if you're his manager you
don't let him fight no but again if you
lose to that the great you know the
little pounding great though you just
chalk it up to be like well you lost him
he's still great you know so I can see
that but John Tate is the kid you want
to take under your wing and just make
sure he's all right that's right
he's that he's a guy who
you know his reading and skill set
levels not great I won't get into
details it's not good it's not it's not
his skill set levels not know his boxing
world class I'm talking about its
reading oh yeah
there's not a lot of education involved
is what you're trying to say anyway well
I watched like nobody needs to reason
bother I feel the same way about a dream
runner I feel like he's just you know 20
Davis stays in that scene though in
Baltimore you know he's Sharonda I mean
that agent brother Qin's mantle changed
coaches or trainers and this trainer is
a former police officer and unknown as
to be a disciplinary and it doesn't like
any of that showboating [ __ ] that's like
sign up you know that's what you get
that's a drumroll oh man that's right oh
not good though who's next Frazier and
browner do you think he's a little bit
of a crossroads man he needs to figure
out because I think two bosses and one
draw now right well no one lost one draw
he losted Mikey Garcia which was just a
[ __ ] terrible matchup for him but the
draw at you know 144 so if you get beat
Vargas Susan there's a ridiculous box if
can beat him you should [ __ ] not hanging
with the you know the upper echelon at
147 where he wants to compete yeah
because he's smaller than most of but
you're not beating the porters the
Thurman's the Spence that's just not
happened to make it strong that's just
not I don't know he's a little bit of a
common girl Spence is the guy who just
he beats everybody
Crawford might have something to say
about that at boxing boxing especially
at that weight class in that area sake
boxing boxing at 147 is their event at
147 140 and then UFC at 155 145 that's
good to get I mean if you want to save
Fighting's on the decline I beg to
differ
never been better yeah boxing in
fighting boxing MMA it's [ __ ] great
right nowadays Matt's got to pay
attention it really is
she's gonna pay attention that was a
crazy fight now uh couple Calgarians
were upset you kept saying at your city
you know it gives that you kept your
city yeah I told me you know it's not
have it I have it locked down and
whatever you want I
say yay or nay that's all I meant oh no
I get that time but now you're legit
headed to my city in Denver and they
keep asking hey please answer our texts
and this is the city the Denver yeah I'm
on my Texas ship ever Denver I go who is
this goes the city of Denver okay and
they go are you okay with Brian coming
I went let me think about it that was
last week was last week
hold on and then the then the the
problem is it's already shot people are
there already waiting in line that
Comedy Works downtown that's where I can
shut this how do works was I was just
there a few months ago when are you sure
it's right if we bring bryan callen we
don't want to offend you in any way yeah
I went huh you know what let me think
about it
come on I never got around to it so not
your worry the yeah give me the LC
though my mom needs Messam tickets your
mom I gotta put your mom and I'll what a
man why you keep your hands off Mike are
you gonna be keeping liver-spotted hands
off my mother I you keep your surprise
hands off my [ __ ] mother okay
are you gonna be there hey you keep your
sir I stand off my [ __ ] nubby Jesus
rise pants off my enemy you're not there
they miss you I'm gonna I'm gonna be
there I'm gonna press myself against
them like a son to me be cheap squeezing
them they're gonna go you're back what
you're hard what's going on your body
feels like you've been working out I go
I have and I'm a mature man I'm 51
you're not that module shark eyes doll
smells gonna be the rupee pickup he will
so I'm gonna look at him and I'm gonna
go hey Jay take that no I'm just gonna
do a nice I'm gonna go grab a beer but
right now I need a little minute in the
green
take a leak and up and mom nothing mom
take a walk hey bro the sisters and I
have a little party you're gonna train
on my mom and Brody's grown Angwin do
you know use gross language but we're
gonna play a game called yeah
that's all it is jack we call game
called
about my psoriasis look like a kosher
bra [ __ ] right yeah it's your bra
you stupid J's going to your show I
think I'm Friday then you're going to
Leon Saturday I'm gonna ask you a really
personal question in your past you've
been alive on this planet for 35 years
right I am done II purely ever had a
gorilla jizz it considering that you and
I are dying no by the way we are yeah we
are carry on them have you ever had this
a personal story have you ever had or
known anyone who's ever had two girls
one who gives you who's giving you
working your route and the other ones
working your mud whistle the other ones
blown the horn
I have not okay I'm just curious I was
that's a personal question
that's a person trying to pull it off
with my mother and that's how I even
said that that that's so disrespectful
that I would even say that out loud I'm
doing but I did start thinking about my
51 years on the planet and you've had
someone do that I'm not gonna say what
kind of savage goes through your old
Rumpole I'm not gonna say what I've had
but but I mean that would be appalling
wouldn't it that there are some girls
that get right into the old mud wasan
they're like well you're gonna work that
era it was first I'm gonna come around
the back and there are they grabbing
hands like this I'm well I get
teeter-totter I will get on this well
you they don't want you to get oh you're
not going anywhere you know you're back
up your long it's like so long and
centipede you're locked in yeah this
it's called the what so what's a good
word for that you're getting bookended
mmm I called your the caboose you're the
caboose you look at boobs
he's a caboose you're the caboose that's
right it's a train called it's called
the human Kabuto you locked in it's
called the human caboose we lock and
load oh and guess what what this one
that's a load oh boy yep oh boy Oh
what's this I get coal coming out the
back
uh-huh no I don't wanna watch that video
at all and you know that's been done
somewhere damn it somewhere in Germany
or Japan
they're in the scat video I don't know
the notes called the caboose man yeah
it's damn it man I'm sorry it is now
well I knew I shouldn't have brought
this up cuz no I'll bring this up and
then I it'd be a disaster well it all
started with my mom I ain't gonna see
you dirty [ __ ] how dare you right now I
didn't the bloody bish rice is the Lord
Commander got a little I got a little
psoriasis right I'm the like right in
the beginning of my if you look at the
crack the top crack part of a crack if
you look just the impure to look in the
inside I got a little surprise that's
all I got a dot no just my crack there's
a little there's some psoriasis there
like what's that what's that red blotch
keep it that I don't put cream on huh no
doesn't hit my dick yet do good right
now though dude I bought this bill might
psoriasis is better some [ __ ] on your
sock those are the worst sock shoe combo
those yeah but you see my oh yeah it's
not good actually look at my leg that's
not terrible yeah yeah oh that cream you
you got do you have any more because um
I bought this belt in downtown LA yeah
this Mexican dude and it looked like you
owned the shops I'm like and I felt
forced to buy the belt I've been wearing
it I think it's cheaper fake brass and
have a rash on my Tumtum you got a rash
on your tongue Tom yeah you're Tom
Tambor I hope yeah I know you're
self-conscious no sometime in that area
nope show me your tongue I can't let I
have to undo my pants on camera so metal
allergies are a real thing yeah I know I
think this is fake Brad yeah when you
you might my grandmother when she had
certain metals came into contact with
her skin her skin would turn black and
then she would get and she would get
peel into she'd get this terrible
peeling oh is it just like crazy I have
my I inherited my look that she's gay
what you should do for it her fingers
would crack dude I had terrible cracking
oh she had something else clearly but
did you ever give a lotion I do have a
lotion that I hope with that yeah I have
a South and in your car nope I have it
in my balls
that's where it lives it works it's
always you and Falls 30 yeah I have it
Liz and not am i 12 and with a couple
good well-placed Yanks people can all be
yours
we deli grow up move
I won't crop up and I'm you I just like
I shouldn't say this but it's Monday I'm
gonna say it I do have that south as
you're asking me your face is up and
you're asking me was total sincerity the
head
no I gotta grow up of course so you deaf
all you do if I do measure oh yeah I
have it
it's called it's my man come all right
man sorry buddy
god damn it you said it ridiculous I
know I don't even have a cap on my on
the end of my dick when you on you
headed to Denver gives a [ __ ]
Thursday this [ __ ] Thursday through
Saturday yep
get your [ __ ] tickets they're still
only a few left
well I'll be the dog oh and then brought
let you know Colusa casino may 5th let's
get out there and get our tickets why
I'm shooting my special inclusive I'm
shooting my special Thalia Hall July
20th in Chicago um I heard it first here
and you're coming out for it and you're
opening for me all right so the fighter
and a kid Brenna's gonna open for me I
think that's very apropos I mean - it's
a beautiful thing yeah I mean that's a
big deal you know this is this is gonna
be a huge special team you're big
especially July 20th and when I'm done
with that I will not be doing the road
for a little while
look yeah and I'm till that I'm doing
the road a lot
July 20th tell your Hall Tommy I mean
you know what the best thing about this
I'm charging my flat feet I'm not going
crazy
what what do you hold on what and don't
be a dick now dude you hit the family
friend I never seen tell y'all
awesome what are you gonna charge me oh
I'll tell y'all like that let me see
that that's what you and I did right
tune yeah I'm gonna tell you how the
place let's get amazing yeah Wow
that's it how are you and I did the Vic
theater together there that was the
that's fast how yeah really all sick
really great food though
you'll love it I don't like it the best
restaurant in the basement
Talia halls [ __ ] Reid that's perfect
be good a huge oh you said now I don't
know what your budget is okay I don't
know I know you're big but became your
showing a beef right that's like a big
deal yeah I make money yeah sorry I
don't get shooting the special sure how
many man see when we do like what 20
yeah 30 20 minutes all right 20 minutes
20 20 minutes and Chicago so the friend
family discount and you want yeah for
obviously friend and family discount I
can't believe you're charging me money
in the first one now listen I'll just do
a quick hour I'm gonna have my team in
of shoes why might a be you're like this
you come out yeah sup guys this is Maya
I'm going back out my rhythm [ __ ] up
the whole thing my god dude it's gonna
be good to d'italia hall we gotta sell
those tickets
well that's thing selling out how many
nights you doing tonight just just know
two shows one night why perfect if he
says one night that's all we got
influenced Saturday bro oh my god I need
your help on what the backdrop is oh
yeah please let me do some of that right
please alright in the marking for it in
the name
I'd love to out of the shirts I kind of
like the idea of bipolar rape because
that's where we are bipolar Apes
oh you're bipolar rape I know I'm not no
I know but I like the idea of calling it
bipolar rate because we are we are
basically humans are capable of sinners
and saints that's interesting what do
you think I don't know we'll talk
generally flow I have an American boner
might be the greatest ability right now
we're talking have you so funny just to
call an American boner the first time
I'm actually trying to say something
with my stand him instead of being a
silly goose and I just call it American
boner
wait I don't get it now don't have
people things economy special you do a
[ __ ] hour TED talk for no you ever
seen I never will you ever seen a with
Nick Swardson what he called one of his
specials no you just see his face like
this he's like this and it says who
farted so [ __ ] puffy
oh my nose is alright who farted oh my
God look at it there's nothing better
than me then come up with tell me
special names I don't have a comedy
special and I have about 60 names in the
bank ready go I'm serious think of name
is NaN seriously who farted
that's hilarious get his nose Wow he
sued we I get him on the show Allah he
wants to do - I know and love that guy
let's get him on leave Thursday you do
any spots in town this week I think I'm
doing a spot tomorrow night I was
supposed to a spot tomorrow night sir
please show oh yeah you're at The Comedy
Store I asked her I had to I suppose do
a spot last night at The Improv but my
voice I got a [ __ ] I'm I think I'm
Friday night I've gotta take it easy you
know Friday night my first time on a
Friday night The Laugh actor didn't
laugh factory Freddie's awesome yeah
that's awesome yeah my voice is back
but tuesdaya to cancel an improv sucks
it's my voices you don't wanna [ __ ]
around how about same trip Lee was on
Miran spot death oh really
he was really good he's great he's real
and he was on merit spot I know what is
so [ __ ] bad man I know - do what -
he's just on there you know they're
doing each other for a while but they're
not like friends friends I think man
just had him on there and then you know
meirin's I think he's on the road and
double or something like that so he he
banks some and that's his thing and puts
in a reason is that see him on there but
I've never heard Sam's story as far as
like you know what state where Sam was
born and raised how he came about and
stuff like that it was good it's really
good yeah on the road I listen up let's
why do I killed by time with podcasts
and books on tape but what are you
what books do you like what I give to
that way with with marinade Bill Simmons
on your bill sit oh yeah those soon is a
special dude because Russell Simmons no
no not the sexual predator Russell
Simmons Ben Simmons
I'm sorry Bill Simmons who owns the
ringer so Bill Simmons the guy who
created 34:30 Grantland have the whole
thing oh yeah sure
podcast Godfather you know it's like
Maren Rogan and Bill Simmons it's kind
of like Simmons got a [ __ ] huge easy
he's a sportswriter in Boston and then
brilliant man he did he did Andre the
Giant documentary oh he does all the
yeah he had a show for a while didn't go
no it's tough it's tough he saw it he
and he said it's interesting because
he's talking about it on on Marin cuz
his whole thing is he and he's like this
he likes podcasts how it's raw and it's
like there's conversation he goes what
if I brought this to TV and he goes what
I learned from that is what you think
works on a podcast doesn't work on TV
just doesn't translate yeah you know
like TV has to be boom boom boom and he
thought he could make that happen on TV
and just never caught on never caught on
that's a different thing so now he has
the ringer and they have all these you
know podcasts kind of Brett he you know
he has his networking from there it's
pretty crazy he's a pioneer man
brilliant brilliant man very very smart
very smart but mayor's been killing and
what Amer not a good point he goes he
was he was I didn't see the show use but
doesn't make it doesn't make sense to me
that you try and put on TV because
podcast says they're kind of lame and TV
has their lane yeah but it doesn't work
on merits not a sports guy is he no not
at all but they didn't talk sports
mayor's not sports guy at all but he
understands the podcast game and he was
on his and so Bill Simmons did the
favorite came on his but the thing is is
Marin was saying that you know that that
kind of that kind of medium for
entertainment doesn't work on TV and he
was for instance like David Letterman
has his kind of a podcast type show
interview show on Netflix and goes and
he has great guest huge gaseous but I
don't see David Letterman sit down for
an
have a conversation I won't see the
witty David David Letterman oh you know
hey I'd rather that's not Letterman's
that's interesting that's not long-form
as not Letterman Sport a is it that's
Rogen's forte that's meirin's forte
yes that's so [ __ ] true and Bill
since two past thirty years doing short
form like quippy [ __ ] you know he's on
Netflix with jay-z and Obama and the
biggest guess in the world so we watch
it and I find and I love that about the
same way I watched it I first of all
I've never thought David Letterman and
there's nothing inherent about David
London oh that's interesting he's not
that interesting when you think about
Letterman he's a busy woman
all right comic he was in a beast now I
was never a beast he was never very good
he was alright as a comic I promise I
won't argue yeah we've never compared
though guys you're friends with I mean
yes so he became a toxic wit once he saw
Jay Jay Leno's worked I think you know
that oh I didn't know that that makes
sense
oh he's the Comedy Store in jail owns
there and like we're doing jaylen is
like I have four set tonight what are
you doing he's like I'm not doing that
yeah yeah he was just never he was very
uh detached and kind of like snarky and
that kind of that Indiana thing but no
one again told me yeah he was never
gonna be a great comic I'm sorry and but
he was he had this thing right here
that's um about him yeah he had this
accessible Americana likeable thing and
he was also irreverent enough and all
that stuff like like you'd never felt he
was kissing the ass of the guest right
yeah he was always going to the back
yeah like he would always give it back
to him like you don't Madonna goes well
you got this helmet you call hair you
thievin always you know he had a good
thing but but um yeah that but there was
nothing about him that's you don't see a
long fool now and have you seen his
beard in that yeah he's not looking
great you know the one thing that David
lavera when he's going through that
whole stuff with the allegations yeah
and he was like you know what I [ __ ] a
few employees yeah because once he owned
it
that was over man that did a good job
he's an old man now that's all but he
doesn't have to look that way he's
probably had to shave for so long and he
said I don't want to shave anymore
but even that like that's a thing you
don't realize when people do like that's
a you know that's there's a lot of
upkeep with that or like that's a it
won't be
all weekend revolting a bit I maybe just
I love it he's on Netflix refuting I
don't know that's an attempt and a style
that's still a certain kind of attempt
at looking a certain way I think it's
not a Nomad look I think beards are in
yep it's a lot of work to do a song with
a big beard that's not easy it's got a
comb that [ __ ] there's oils it's you
know never been more germs in it than a
toilet never been a David Letterman fan
not one never been a fan Corner corner
O'Brien cool not talking about a bro
[ __ ] Cole Bryan how you're talking
about outed man out of all he is a guy
who ride on us an old level of Simpsons
Simpsons he's at the highest level
comedic lame I mean David I mean he's no
no Bryan is a [ __ ] Beast gonna be
beast
I'm just so funny in my opinion jamming
on and David Letterman can't hold him I
never found JLo funny I liked him if I
had to pick between Jay Leno and David
Letterman growing up I always watched
Jay Leno yeah but kind of Conan O'Brien
is brilliant well how would he not be
with the biggest head on the planet
she's a big dude he's very so in person
he is tall the very big man with a huge
head and he's fantastic I think he's the
best in the business and I know people
know him personally and he's hilarious
remember when he got [ __ ] over every
when he did the Jay Leno Show then Jay
came back like now I'm just [ __ ] with
he does not have a lot of fans I'll tell
you that much really yep they always say
he acts like a nice guy I don't know Jay
so I don't want to say anything too bad
but I just haven't heard you know to my
years I've heard the opposite maybe yeah
but that that medium though with podcast
it doesn't really translate TV cuz
people listen to you talk when they're
going to work when they're in the car
the working out with TV it's different
this yeah long forms huge man long form
is a conversation not an interview to
there's a difference sometimes what
Rogen's strength is in a lot of ways is
he's having a conversation with only
conversation and then he'll ask a
question that comes to him organically
where he's curious about it he doesn't
have them ever change our no matter what
you
it's produce where you're firing that
off yet you listen that's the art of
having a conversation very much so very
much so if I did and you know pod cat is
giving way to the podcast TV is giving
way too you know I mean look like the
movie star who was a movie star nowadays
it's it's like rocked
yeah very few though right so it's it's
oh yeah it's all yeah it's so dissipated
I thought I thought was interesting
though because Bill Simmons who's been
on the forefront of certain media
switching within the sport he was
working for the the Boston Globe or
whatever and he said news kiddo he had
an email like email 96 and then he was
riding for ESPN and something would
happen you know there's a big trade or
something like that and he said he knew
newspaper was in trouble because the
traders was breaking news well he wrote
it and put it online everyone saw it two
days later the Boston Globe on Friday
came out with breaking news
blah blah blah trade and he's like well
you're two days old brother and he goes
oh [ __ ] and so he sort of knew all his
folks online yeah yep
he's like he's just always been at the
forefront things and you know he's a
rider for Jimmy Kimmel oh he's a rider
for Jimmy Kimmel forever yeah very very
good rider funny guy oh yeah and they
say he's writing for Jimmy Kimmel is
just like god he's always wanting to do
something else I love Jimmy Kimmel by
the way he's a guy tell most brilliant
yeah so Jimmy Fallon yeah great I'll
take Conan's the most talented man on TV
though I think so yeah I hate that case
yeah a beast what do we got for current
events um the first one is actually a
little bit older but we talked about it
a while ago how Carrie Underwood says
she would not look the same anymore how
she had a horrific accident do district
before you go on this reminds me of
American Idol I was watching last night
you know there's a there's a I how do I
say this
just transgender dude on American
ologists up as a woman across her as a
woman can sang saying like you know
[ __ ] sing in the top 14 blowing and
everyone else is young like 18 16 19
this drag dry
crossdresser comes on and [ __ ] lays
it oh you got about this is the one of
the facial hair no I it's the only
transgender on American Idol chin oh
you'll you would know if he's seen she
cut her face all up and there are some
faint scars there all right let's see
alone last night she [ __ ] ate of oxy
that's her I made it through to the top
fifty back row it's the end of the line
after I started getting messages on
social media sweetie people attack my
way my sexuality telling me that I was
horrible that you know that I sucked but
I really hear that I shouldn't be Who I
am and I suppose you transgender wrong
way you'll see it kills me inside
it kills me inside almost as much as
people were telling me that I should
kill myself I was complaining lots of
things that shouldn't happen I just kind
of disappeared from the world for a
while anyway about the crop how stupid
matters yeah
myself you just hate him because that's
how he is because he feels more feminist
and as masculine nobody hated myself
look recreates itself as a way that I
could not have imagined oh they must
have had some bad [ __ ] come up
we're gonna turn you into a girl just
know it was his decision so how he
didn't make it this before he came back
and now he dresses up as a girl on stage
accurate for this prime get ready for
this [ __ ] I get chills from have a
raging boner why were you from San
Antonio Texas big hairy oh yeah girl
gotta represent for the Texas Queens are
you doing tell me about your journey
here to LA I work by day serving fish on
a platter to lovely the seafood
restaurant so that don't really pay the
bills to get to elevate girl and then
I'm a professional part-time woman by
night what does that mean it means I do
this when the Sun Goes Down amazing and
what's your what's your iLike all three
of these but as judges they're bad
they're too friendly like there's no one
do you think she's hot it's Katy Perry
boy named Adam
oh really the fans really see this tune
maybe top and why do you think to
profess Lord told her she sings I know
the story but you gotta start from right
when she sings together I was just a
chubby little runt - you're not worried
okay here we go
[Music]
well what can you find last night by the
way
no that's whatever that's decent fine
last night's cuz she's that training now
this is America I love America
oh why this look what yes that's it this
is April 2nd so was it a brand new
episode
yeah but play this one ok here this
one's good
I think her so good do they have to play
her story every time
[Music]
this is part of what makes our culture
strong and interesting everybody but
people are hating on Sojourner
[Music]
we cool
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you help everyone know this is
[ __ ] that Radiohead song right yeah
listen to the way he's singing this [ __ ]
say she used the right pronouns but go
ahead and hate on this person for doing
neither's come on man this person's
channeling this woman one love dude
you're talking about like I said as he
said a chubby latino guy who who serves
fish and look at this [ __ ] with somebody
bears crying should cry over this
[Music]
Oh
this works you're in space it's crazy
she looks disgust no it's crazy it's
glorious yeah it sounds like she's an
actual girl that's a good girl singer
yep which is trippy trippy that's a
little Latino boy Jim he's already
always felt obviously more like this
young woman and then we has when he's on
stage she just takes his [ __ ] persona
on a kid last night though was that's
last night was like that's like all
average I was like god this is weak and
then she came out and Katie Barry's like
Jesus crying man that will it's almost
like you you know say what you will but
obviously she feels or he feels more
like himself or whoever he is or whoever
rest like that whoever that person that
their best is yeah is that and why
wouldn't you want ever so you playing
character well oh because they make
beautiful music yeah and because it made
you you it's nice in your ears but but
you know this is well because it's a
threat to the normal this is my thing no
DC she makes it into the top like three
because she's transgender I don't think
I don't think America is gonna vote her
in like that even though she's the best
singer they might I don't I think they
would I don't think so mmm I hope so I
don't thinks I'm gonna be variance to
see that I bet they will you're gonna
watch it aren't you I pay attention
I won't cuz I'm too big you're gonna
slide in there DMS I yeah well yeah like
Carrie Underwood kid into its face I was
just getting this ready yeah so do you
remember we talked about how she had
this horrific she fell yeah
she had 40 to 50 stitches on her face is
like all here oh I should say she was
just saying like she would she's like
warning her fans I'm not gonna look the
same way I got back on she [ __ ] her kids
didn't recognize her we just what kind
of father [ __ ] my she looks normal to me
that's the thing so fans are pissed off
she did the ACMs I think I was like a
week or two ago Louis and her face looks
flawless she's gorgeous and and she's
such a good singer
you know I don't know Carrie Underwood
here oh my god
yeah Carrie don't be too dramatic cuz
your face looks fine that's why fans
were pissed off
fans wonder that she blew a person maybe
or jorts covered up by makeup and great
plastic surgery maybe she's out over
like 30 surgeries I don't know but uh
yeah that was the story of that this
particular thing ok onward family she's
urban you gotta quit with the [ __ ]
highlights in the air cut you've gotta
stop you're too old for that [ __ ] yeah
I'm a fan of his we got quit that I
don't care about him I'm sure he's great
nice guy I know how I'm a girl I said
I'd suck his dick just out of respect
that's fair you guys know you have to
suck his dick cuz out of respect he's so
talented that Sal first day I was like
that's really cool of you yeah God not
me
I would bully him that's not you don't
have to while we're on this music stuff
so I messed up a story last two weeks
ago with Ed Sheeran remember I said that
Tim McGraw was suing ed Sheeran it's
actually know that girl that there's the
word songwriting they're suing ed
Sheeran and Tim McGraw and then I guess
there's writing inside thing the the
lawsuit where Tim McGraw says he's
backing up at Sharon however if there is
damages that they have to pay that he
was just a singer he didn't write the
song so he's essentially saying it's not
my fault those things are I have a buyer
lawyer yeah all those things you buy
your you tell them to say that what do I
say yeah ok write the statement form you
know here's what we're gonna say on
statement he's on the phone he goes okay
that sounds good
yep correct that's how that works well
don't she being a celebrity myself I can
tell you take it easy man avicii I'm not
really into EDM music huge yeah
enormous and young twenty eight years
old yeah well are you past a friend and
worked in Vegas and the night scene and
they were saying to saying that he he
had a residency at Wynn and actually
fired him from that because he was on
stage and fell asleep because he's on
heroin he's on here Oh he had his
gallbladder and spleen removed so he was
doing he's partying hard to heroin and
they knew was a prob
yeah they knew was a problem then he was
just spinning out of control okay
but did you see in his home town on the
belt you see them playing you know that
like the church playing his music in the
morning no oh my god do you guys not pay
idiots all over this no that's that's
just as the main hitter all yeah that's
no but it's good you type in church
bells for god sakes Church just type in
Avicii church bells dumb blood home town
their dad's church bells pay fitting
tribute you know get a Stones out a fan
question on my show about I guess a
who's better at Google chant or Stevie
Wonder oh my god
I voted Stevie that's true all right
that's why other is
this hometown how cool is as they
welcome
I want to be there for some reason I
like Sweden I've never been
it's beautiful Stockholm is Buddha
wanna go to fonts right now leaving
Europe fix it's pretty cool all right
and in the composers I showed them
playing it and they have it written up
at 28 and what a [ __ ] shame yeah and
I was talking to someone who knows him
pretty well I said the problem is is you
know he got super famous young and
there's no there's no blueprint of okay
you're gonna get this famous you can get
this amount of money and these guys are
on the road 300 days a year
they're in the club scene you gotta be
up all night so drugs are obviously
something that's part of the business
and he's Young's has all this money and
access to women and private jets and
hotels and then you just you find
yourself lost yeah and then you [ __ ]
fall as an arrow
oh we know one thing fame and money
doesn't save you from addiction like
family you don't get famous and and
really rich and all of a sudden you're
like things are so much better now like
it tends to be something more than
that's a bummer man this station seminar
well EDM it's it's a kind of a drug
thing it's a culture like you know if
you're gonna go those big shows
especially Molly and I yeah yeah I've
never really heard of heroin working
I'll tell you what I've never done drugs
in my life man but if you had a line of
devil's dandruff in Calgary after my
second show I probably need this big old
smashing mind and sniffed it up yeah you
would
I hear pure below is more yellow than it
is white I don't know why I know it just
know that it is then I call that The
Devil's drip Devil's drip drip another
death Verne Troyer
we brought the good news bear I mean
this this all happened over the past
weekend Vern she's only 49 years old but
he passed away small people don't live
that long in general right they have a
shorter life span yeah that the right
thing especially with his condition like
he has extreme tourism but uh I guess
his friends and family are saying they
their him suicide yet he's always super
depressed did you ever see him on the
was the show the real yeah that shelf
god I [ __ ] love every reality No
it was on vh1 right huh and they which
Verne Troyer they're celebrities are in
the house
she'd be hammered on his little and just
[ __ ] peon shit-faced I am the surreal
a real-life
I thought tell you what one of the
greatest shows ever The Surreal Life its
most was on that cast that uh that Brady
guy nor the middle Brady yeah I got
married who else was on there just click
on Surreal Life Wikipedia for God's
first no I'm yours Ben can somebody tell
me where Mike Myers all you when were my
husband you don't worry that yeah he's
in Canada's [ __ ] Shrek Castle no I
have made 1 billion dollars playing a
green character on TV but he hasn't what
he was track all he wrote and created
Trek he wrote in crazy Wow the game he's
out all this he wrote and created Shrek
now I'm pretty sure he was the the voice
actor I'm not sure if he wrote the voice
actor but still Wow Bridget Neeson
Jordan Knight uncle Joey Dave Chloe
uncle Joey was on there yeah what's this
what's this might be what's this for he
doesn't think what shows it's a real
life the one that Verne Troyer was on
yeah he was great hey Jerry was the real
Jose Canseco's on there it was the
greatest show ever jealous because he
can take who's got our toaster you know
I really yeah you know my boy Mike stud
dates his daughter I've seen Jose
Canseco's daughter she's a dime piece
Oh [ __ ] smoke they can say it was a
striking-looking man very good Wallach
here you're looking just so tall and
he's just bigger and stronger than
everybody you know I need to hit up Mike
stud and see fully and Jose Canseco on
Air Force I mean I'd be great probably
don't talk about Gustav
huh but I don't talk about juice your
boy was open about it
MC Hammer hammer was on this I'm
surprised to him or did that China man
I'd say what celebrity AB trying a dead
friend - a dead who's 10 awesome
Pinochet dead trying to dead China died
yeah that's right she did who's that
that worship bronson pinchot died you
know China
yeah she was the Rustler yeah she's your
type too our clitoris was his bad
attitude that's all did you see come on
man have a little respect for the virus
was as big as a powerful respect for the
devil yeah
hey he's a lightweight Balki died no
he's alive you son of a [ __ ]
now Bronson Pinochet died are you sure
yeah does it say that doesn't say it
says he's alive
it was 58 years old he didn't die you
son of a [ __ ] you're Balki great show
oh no not him Oh Oh his body in that the
guy who is dying that is it the guy who
starred in that not the other guy oh I
know you're talking about you're talking
about the late Pope I know you're going
this you're talking about Chris Benoit
yeah I would have sketch in every
changes was good
Balki what a great name I wanted him a
dog Balki you hear about this Trump
partying pardoning Jack Johnson the
boxer did he sleep what was that what
was his crime Stephen with a black woman
are married big so it was taking her
across like yeah it's called the Mann
Act yeah which is made for sex
trafficking but they use it for him
because they didn't like obviously black
people well definitely pardon thank you
nothing trail my party better late than
never
I mean Jesus name Trump's gonna pardon
pardon all all of the people caught up
in the most candle yes like his lawyer
there August or Allah for man afford he
did that the word is that don't fight it
fight the government let him spend all
the resources and then just lettin all
that time and just wink at him cuz
because now you're gonna get a full Wow
Jesus I [ __ ] you the reason why this
one's interesting because uh cell that's
just alone isn't one I called them and
told them about this boxer the
heavyweight boxer from was like yes you
really want Brock
the woman named fly whatever rocky
clicked that's weird
when semester owns call shots to the
president yeah um how did you see that
one I forget where she's from Mac you're
not caught in sex trafficking it's right
next oh this girl have you guys ever
seen Smallville I grew up on Smallville
nope sure she's sexy oh that's what I do
you should see her on the show she was
so cute on the show
Allison backhoe resident roll up and
ledge sex cult yeah I would you arrest
me for sex no sex trafficking business
traffic mrs. Sachs called hold on so
that's the cost that did try for alleged
role in a notorious upstate sex slave
cult oh she's never appeared Friday so I
Crimean forced labor the bus comes less
than a month after next time leader
Keith whatever was called Collard and
they same charges they've been hiding
out since their slaves October went
public with their experience Nicole no
what's those slave say though I was
gonna say Brian maybe we were part of
this cult when do we know she looks like
she was into sadomasochism and somebody
got mad I think she was brainwashed just
like all women were being branded like
cattle Mac allegedly placed her hands on
their chests and told him to feel the
pressure within the bound to think that
the master and to think of their master
it's the actress first lured the woman
into the secret society with Nick in the
room known as The Vow who and then
controlled them which means persuaded
them and they're providing collateral
like embarrassing photos and statements
to use as blackmail
what a bad person then I allegedly groom
the slaves for sex with Ren here but
this is a whole sexual thing that they
all did ordering in to adhere to
extremely restrictive diets so their
butts are clean refrain from eating
salads from refrain refrain from
removing their pubic damn homie and stay
celibate homie like anal thing yeah
she'll support stem just posed naked for
photos she didn't force anybody to put
to anything I love him they said he
forced them to they might have bro
including one occasion closer pictures
of their vaginas was there they were
well yeah that woman is not going to
force anybody I love this Mac
other slave masters allegedly made their
slaves participated in readiness drills
requiring them and respond to requests
at the time of the day or nights there
seriously sleep-deprived this is what
everybody did nobody was kidnapping them
and forcing them at gunpoint this is a
whole second black guy out here but it
sure but people get in all this [ __ ] if
you were to join a cult shut up I'd be
let me ask I just like the pictures I um
yeah
leave me dead eyes yeah you defend that
[ __ ] little too hard part of this cult
you probably soit's cult I don't even
know what you mean by part of I have
given money and I've you're one of the
leaders you force people clean their
[ __ ] out too they call me the Dark
Lord that was around Smallville she was
really cute no she's a perv and I love
her it's cute she's all right and that
girl's these people she's mousy yeah
babble right here this I know you're
above a big perverted ring of a bunch of
people who are into this [ __ ] they got
to go there and they all [ __ ] I mean
that's it and some people are dominance
and do I have a membership there it is
boy do I got to way too hard to pay for
this [ __ ] who's mousy right who's all
in the middle right notes this is
Kristin Kreuk she was a star of the show
so Superman and this is like the girl
before Lois Lane Smallville now it's big
bill in my pants my pants [ __ ]
sorry what else you got Jun let's get
off this for everyone kills Brian [ __ ]
off that's Christian too hard too hard
in the paint
this girl was actually part of it like
in the beginning for the six cuz there
wasn't supposed to be like this Powerman
empowerment to women kind of guru group
later yeah then you had and then you had
a charismatic dude who is like this is
all for me to get laid all cults are
always some [ __ ] guys sleeping with a
girl yeah
young naive or dude she was in it yep no
she didn't damn I'll be in there
participate on the sex stuff those
things exist everywhere know how we'll
know what made it be we invited one of
those groups I've been invited hey hey
hey what do you want to know the truth
I've been to some parties I've been
invited I'll being in the know I would
invite it to a high-end one you got to
pay into it I was like wow interesting
and I heard some [ __ ] - there are some
high-level [ __ ] in it how about
that this [ __ ] goes on all day long
yes there are dominance and subs [ __ ]
[ __ ] off tied up yes all that's done way
too huh meeting the way to a to drive
beaten sleep-deprived there's a guy I
know a billionaire from England who had
a girl band friend who was into this
[ __ ] and she and her friend he would
keeps you in a friend in a closet and
then take them out [ __ ] okay you want
me to keep going
I happen to know which one's Meribah way
to go in there but my friends kind of
stopped being friends with this guy I
knew him through my other friend why I
go why goes dude he got into a big he
was telling me about he got into a big
plastic jar a human side plastic jar I'm
into this they put a seal on it well
that's cool and then hey I'm into it
there's there was a tube okay there's a
long to him still and then he had honey
girl sings girls okay girls farting into
the to calm out I'm out I'm not kidding
I know he was breathing all the farts he
was burying them I don't know he was
naked in the tube very wealthy man he
probably aged I pulled her handsomely to
farting that - yeah he did and they were
the hot girls that were farting hard
what did they do to fan and by the way
they were given a diet that would create
gas and they farted into that tube John
man so he'll be a real lowlife to take
the money
is nothing there's all kinds of weird
[ __ ] like thanking you Matt can you
imagine what plating your plane today
can you imagine going to LA can try to
go to LA to be a movie star
and they see no your partner yeah which
happened
Elsie's going yeah bad I mean I got the
big break but you know funny I'm alright
I heard story how'd you get this car
tell Aaron 14 when I remember a dot-com
guy I heard a story about a dot-com guy
who I had met once the idea I don't need
this guy don't make me throw up
I gotta don't find weird mousy guy and
he paid girls thousands of dollars and
he's lying my coffee table Brian he
would poo on the coffee table
there I said it wait so you just lay on
like a black coffee when they'd [ __ ] on
top of it he would walk on a glass
coffee table and you'd look it up you
know you're thinking mmm that makes I'd
throw up everywhere you can't pay me
enough money
weird [ __ ] um now when girl more
concerned the girls are willing to do it
when girls do porn and they have anal
scenes they will try to eat nothing but
salad for a couple days keep their
whistle soon we're going way to earn the
pay on all this I know a lot of stuff
what else you got Jen you scare me man
this really hot chick her nickname is
cocaine babe because she was so into
like posting stuff on Instagram that she
accepted a trip from some random guy
that gave her like cocaine to just ship
around with her so the her usual yeah
she was a meal but her motivation for it
was she can take pictures and Instagram
all those like exotic locations yeah so
she sends to eight years in prison for
shipping for having cocaine in her
luggage that she was shipping for the
guy in America Australia you gotta know
that if you're gonna scroll down and
there's no more pictures made yeah
there's more coke it's gonna come with
lots of penalties you're just a mule you
know working for the drug cartel yeah
there
very cute that's the one that got here
this question she's alright
yeah the question is I mean how sorry
are ya of almost raelia you don't see
American uh none uh robear's is his last
name
well you know milena grigorash so maybe
he's young you're Tom and you don't
think you're gonna get caught I don't
think she deserves eight years at all no
not eight years
come on my name drugs should be legal
how about that I think finally kids
would get her battle yep eight years
stupid that's her oh wow well Canadian
delicious Canadian wishes well I will
just don't let you give her out now yep
she needs to smuggle Brian's dick in her
mouth and my nuts in her ass that would
hurt you're not so bad Elaine how would
you put your nuts first no I want to
fall back everyone in the list is in her
ass and I she's going to jail and you
have to say that out loud
well I'm not putting my dick anywhere
near there number one number two because
I'm a good man and you're gonna put your
balls you said it on this show she needs
my balls in her ass no I said you are
would you move your balls up and push
them with your fingers and it'll be
tough that is a horrible to heard that
you should do eight years for that you
should do eight years for the back I
want to end this podcast what else do we
have
tell me right now that's I would all's I
wouldn't hurt no I would try and smuggle
drugs in the North Korea for that girl
she's hot as [ __ ] if she said job I'm in
North Korea I need you just smuggle
eight pounds of cocaine your rectum and
then she's crying and her lashes are all
wet with tears you don't want two
speakers seriously no make her be our
intern pretty but there's cocaine let
him talk cocaine baby [ __ ] around
baby just paying for it though he'll
pose for Playboy and come out with a
nice nest egg actually pose now and then
save that money okay right now bro she's
in prison get some pictures risk it all
you had smuggled Ruiz in North Korea for
that bid for cocaine she was just
dealing with a little cocaine that it
should it's pretty much it
there's another one but it's another sad
one I don't if it's sad but it's
probably like a heavy topic let's see so
three parents are suing Alex Jones for
defamation good thing our - look he's
younger than me
what yeah Wow hey do I look older or
younger than him you look much younger
really feel like medium with very
similar hours on that no you do not hit
that I'm saying we both mess his voice
is insane he says all the stuff in that
as soon as he gets in trouble he says I
was just kidding it's like well Oh 8u
you like this Sam Tribble he's going
hard on conspiracy theories I'm Erin
Merryn [ __ ] shut him down like you do
he's like no conspiracies are for people
who aren't very educated and want
something to gravitate towards and lock
onto because they don't take the time to
read actual books he shits on them so
bad he's no no I'm sure there's some
that are too sure sure sure
but in general anyone can get their
bachelor's degree in conspiracy
what you can't do is get your bachelor's
degree Natural History it takes time to
learn that stuff yes that's why people
gravitate towards he's just take it
man's a smart [ __ ] well-read dude
yeah you're using an iPhone and all the
technology that goes in there when you
deny that they were earth is round but
you're using your iPhone and satellites
work on that principle you don't even
know to say you dudes lying and taking
the cab these curvature that's where you
fly when you go to from Saudi Arabia
dude you don't have over the bro we
don't have flat earthers really you
don't have to just all of us are rolling
our eyes hilarious now I want you
smuggle this [ __ ] around
mind me I could do a slightly worse I
could do eight years much tomorrow what
do you think about after the show I
don't know the first time I heard
smuggling the speaking the first time I
heard that expression I was with a good
friend of mine he had his girlfriend
this is a long time ago and I was with a
girl and she was hot and we started
talking about a foursome kind of joking
around but my friend said I don't like
your
I'm not attracted to him and my girl
goes and his girl goes she looks at me
she goes could I [ __ ] you and and my
buddy goes if he dropped his [ __ ] in
your mouth you're not gonna not suck it
I know I went and dropped his [ __ ] any
brother you see and I never have to use
a key for a smuggle there the word of
the day smoked out and I smuggle would
have been good I heard tomorrow said
well if you if if you're on the ground
he smuggles his dick in your mouth I'm
gonna stop it
cuz the key word of the day smuggle
smuggle he said drop I like words like
the heft of my [ __ ] smuggle smuggle is
funny when she feels the heft of my
piece like there's no how much would you
dig really way not a lot no depress this
[ __ ] out of you cuz you'd have to wait
out full blood if a butcher said if you
go I'll have a just one dick and then
they put it on is it even a pound yeah I
would know I've seen so much meat
attackers know I've seen some all I've
seen some [ __ ] whoppers yeah you two
three pounds no two three pounds well
Google how much does the average penis
guys a pork chop there porkchop see what
happened you can one pork chop well
wonder what are we doing on our lives
now and the reason our bacon chingu is
not showing enough students because he
gets harassed by his listeners those
parents get called up and told they're
full of [ __ ] they're dealing with that
and they could call it by moral oh and
they lost their children yeah he's a
[ __ ] more that's nice I don't think
it's gonna be answered just ready
what is your penis way ya know this is
crazy
bounces oh you don't we went to put 2 5
ounces 28.3 5 grams
yeah no I don't know it's really tiny
speak for yourself sir I mean I got a
heavy dog if you like if you want to
smuggle your dick in Brian's mouth go
see mean Denver
Friday Saturday yeah and then see me a
closer could see I'm like let's see a
rash on your tongue no let me share Tom
Tom rash
nah let you smuggle it in that's where
the day not this weekend but next May
4th and 5th I'm at the Mall of America
House of comedy if I don't have my if I
do have my voice I'll be there
that's an ex weekend May 4th and 5th and
after that may I think 12 to the fort
I'm at West Nyack New York and then June
I'm in Houston to get a tea vodka calm
for Brian and myself and also the one
love vintage calendar drop Wednesday
night 5:00 p.m. Pacific
kid I'm T viki.com just to find the kid
were out your voice is gone